I was asked to serve on a faculty
committee back in the year 2000 by then
president Chuck vest and the charge to
our committee was to come up with a new
strategy for e-learning for MIT everyone
else was doing
Iranian MIT wasn't and so the president
felt that we should come up with a new
and bold idea for MIT of course
year 2000 was still the era of the
dot-com days and so the Assumption going
in was that we would create an MIT calm
and I enter into some kind of venture
maybe take up the materials that faculty
created and sell them yeah that was one
idea but as we got into the discussion
there were maybe seven or eight of us it
got smaller as the months went by I
became apparent to us that the idea of
MIT comm was not the right idea there
are a number of reasons for it
we interviewed about 60 organizations
that were doing Irani and from those
interviews the one thing that we learned
was that this is really a tough area to
do business in that was one one question
that we had we did try to do to build
business models we had Booz Allen
Hamilton people helping us and we worked
very hard at creating a number of
business models we did lots of surveys
to get credible data and the business
models that we were able to create the
most credible one had us starting year
one and about year five we'd break even
now which is not unusual for a venture
but the problem with that business model
was that after year five you've sort of
flattened there's no this sort of
hockey-stick uptick in in in revenue and
we thought you know if we're going to do
something we wanted to see at least the
potential of having major source of
revenue that could help in idea it
didn't seem to be there the the most
important reason was that we interviewed
about 60 faculty members who had already
put up their materials on the web on
their own and we wanted to see what
their motivation was if we're going to
do a mighty comm we need to understand
the Faculty's motivations and so we
interviewed every one of them and
without exception they told us one
they're doing this to try to improve
their classroom teaching to they are not
getting compensated and three that they
were conned they were sacrificing their
own time research time and with their
family to do this so this is you know
where you find MIT Faculty's real
commitment I mean real commitment to
teaching and that's what we found and
when we discussed this in the committee
was October of year 2000 this was the
last meeting before we had to start
writing a report to president vest we
said you know it doesn't seem right that
we would take teaching materials from
these faculty members who are committed
to teaching and taking that and turning
it into business and so that was pretty
much the final thing we needed here to
say no MIT but we had to report to the
president and give him some bold idea
for MIT in the e-learning space and
particularly based on the what the 60
faculty member of 16 faculty members
told us about MIT faculty is very deep
they deep commitment to teaching
why don't we create a system that's
exactly the opposite exactly the
opposite of what we started with and
what the rest of the world was doing and
say we're going to just give it away
just give it away so that anyone
anywhere in the world can take advantage
of MIT Faculty's commitment to education
that's how we started with
OpenCourseWare if you look at
OpenCourseWare and see why it's been so
successful why he has resonated with the
faculty
I remember just a few days after MIT
announced OpenCourseWare it was
front-page article in New York Times a
young faculty member came up to me and
said that the day MIT announced
OpenCourseWare was the proudest day of
his career at MIT and why did he say
that why did it resonate so much with
the faculty the reason I believe is
because OpenCourseWare it's not just
OpenCourseWare separate from MIT but
OpenCourseWare is very much a mission
that mit has as an as an institution if
you look at the MIT mission not the OCW
mission MIT mission Norma where they
says that MIT is committed to generating
disseminating and preserving knowledge
and to bring this knowledge to bear on
all the great challenges of the world
mit has traditionally fulfilled that
requirement that that mission with basic
research but now with OpenCourseWare we
can also fulfill that mission with our
teaching by disseminating and preserving
our teaching materials